he was he was definitely with us he was
definitely with us and I don't know
where he is now but he was he's right
behind the building no he's definitely
in the building he has to be in the
building I saw him okay he was 100
should I go check on him or yeah yes
please help because he was right he was
with us he was with us all right I'll
just go get him jack
oh hey Kelly
you look awesome thank you you well
what's wrong buddy I'm not going out
there why
because everybody said we were going to
get dressed in costumes and I'm the only
stupid guy that got dressed in a costume
and I'm not going out there now no
they're stupid you look awesome I love
Bowser I think it was like a really
funny trick they played on me like we're
all gonna get dressed in character and
then they didn't and I can't get it off
now it's like someone put super glue in
there I think you look awesome thank you
Kelly yeah
I'm not even talking to you guys ah so
mad at you I am so mad at you